for over a hundred and twenty five years
we've been bringing people together
today we'd like people to come together
on something that concerns all of us
obesity the long-term health of our
families and the country is at stake and
as the nation's leading beverage company
we can play an important role the
well-being of our families and
communities concerns everyone and
finding a solution will take continued
effort from all of us
but at coca-cola we know when people
come together we can make a real
difference coca-cola is under fire this
morning a soda giant donated millions to
spread the message that Americans paid
too much attention to what they eat and
drink instead of focusing on how much
they exercise most of the focus and so
they're eating too much eating too much
eating too much
blaming fast-food blaming sugary drinks
and so on and there's really virtually
no compelling evidence that that in fact
is a cause it's very clear that around
the world the populations are getting
fatter the big problem is we don't
really know the cause we don't really
know the cause we don't really know the
cause
[Music]
[Music]